plus de justice sociale
c'est ce que réclament les chiliens qui
descendent dans la rue depuis un peu
plus d'un an le prix à payer une
violente répression policière qui a déjà
coûté la vie à une trentaine de
personnes
ce dimanche c'est par les urnes que les
protestataires avaient tenté de changer
les choses
le référendum initialement prévue en
avril est reporté en raison de la crise
sanitaire propose de renouveler la
constitution héritée de la dictature
pinochet
première question posée aux électeurs
voulez vous une nouvelle constitution
si la réponse est positive la suivante
demande quels types d'organismes doit
rédiger la nouvelle constitution
deux choix s'offrent alors aux électeurs
l'assemblée constituante composée de
citoyens élus ou l'assemblée
constituante mixte où siègeraient
citoyens élus et parlementaires pour les
manifestants ce référendum sonne comme
une avancée mais pas comme une fin en
soi c'est une lutte générale tout ne
repose pas sur la constitution donc une
fois le référendum terminée nous
continuerons à descendre dans la rue
jusqu'à ce que tout ce qui doit être
changé au chili soit changée tous cette
injustice sociale
je suis contre le fait que la policière
de l'eau parce que même s'il ya des gens
ici qui jettent des pierres etc ce n'est
pas juste il y en a encore beaucoup
d'autres qui viennent pour protester
pacifiquement et on en paye tous le
prime ici reste à voir si cet appel aux
urnes apaisera les tensions au chili ou
s'il creusera un peu plus le fossé entre
le pouvoir et ses opposants